salut l'heure est grave parce que ça
fait [ __ ] de plus de douze heures que
j'attends de faire cette vidéo je vous
ai hier soir aux alentours de 20h
j'adore de l'état inutile c'est un tweet
qui vous demandait de faire des photos
montages marrant avec les photos
ci-dessous nokia on montre du doigt on
fait le super saiyan on tient quelque
chose on sait pas corps à à l'émission
de cette photo même si tu fais pas de
montage est terrible une onde engueuler
quelqu'un est dans mon deuxième tweet
c'était ces photos là voilà une belle
indications un doigt un ninja ninja est
à la recherche de quelque chose j'ai
lutté littéralement pour ne pas aller
sur twitter regarder mais mention j'ai
galéré je mourrais d'envié de voir ces
photomontages que vous avez fait
mesdames et messieurs c'est parti pour
observer vos photos montages un mec
j'attends sale [ __ ] ou la baronne qui
s'est déchaîné et et photos - inspiré ce
matin chez squeeze j'ai terminé mes
vidéos pour lundi mardi mercredi et au
non [ __ ] non j'ai pas finir montage et
clément oui clément qui s'est transformé
en farhot d'ailleurs à temps et a fait
une bd avec fini mon montage avant
demain je compte sur toi je peux pas
désolé vieux d'où tu refuses hockey
pardon mais c'est quoi ça sa banane spin
max génial
excusez moi pardon j'étais obligé de
crier mais vrai qu'ici tu me fais chier
et hop un stagiaire en deux mois à
utiliser cette photo a tellement juste
titre en espérant que le prochain et un
meilleur fredo the end mais qu on a
causé par le meilleur c'est sûr y'a pas
comme ça varone mec tu t'es franchement
phare ode voilà c'est mérité blog chez
dorcel squeeze découvre une nouvelle
passion
il ya juste un problème de proportion et
de détourage sur cette photo mais sinon
c'était pas l'idée était là et m'a aidé
dans celle qui répond ah ah ah ah non
mais attendez ça suffit l'histoire n'est
pas celle que vous croyez
oh là là on en est là j'aime bien lire
sur mon doigt
[ __ ] vous n'êtes pas mes abonnés pour
rien je vous aime je veux le prout aaa à
la taille des titans vous êtes fichiers
j'aime beaucoup
bienvenue dans le nouveau mmorpg world
of squeeze choisissez votre classe
inspecteurs guerrier saiem épéistes
brèche ninja retrait mignon je
choisirais personnellement le ninja
c'est un faux intéresse personne mais
souvenez-vous depuis la vidéo ce qu'on a
dit j'adore de les détails inutiles
voilà j'ai passé toute la soirée j'ai
intitulé mon oeuvre the floor il ce
placement de produit
[ __ ] regarder qui sont tellement doué
vous êtes trop fort avec les vieux les
vieilles thème départ mais de mac faye
carlito derrière bravo vraiment puissant
fort
quelles sont ces dames qui font des
photos comme ça ça n'a pas de sens merci
pour tout c'est pas toi
superbe vidéo vous m s il ya plusieurs
jours la vidéo pour me faire descendre
sur terre c'est pas celle là là c'est
fini c'est bon je vais bien en référence
au logo de nike c'est très très beau
vous avez énormément d'imagination c'est
vraiment donc simple efficace c'est
l'ironie papa et oubliez pas le polo
fait comme squeeze merci les mecs fait
sa pub en plus de ça le mec fait sa pub
à les retrouvailles à ça me brise le
coeur
ce que tu viens de faire mais c'est très
bien fait marc dorcel qui nous tweete
une photo de cul je suis avec mes vous
n'avez pas honte mais c'est des zigotos
chez marc dorcel mec à tort à des
batailles mais n'obtient pas pour
m'humilier là après je publierai le
respect était dans cette direction
non mais bon après ba squeeze dix
minutes et une seconde c'est magnifique
au plus tard dix minutes et une seconde
à en référence en référence au fait
quand ta vidéo fait dix minutes tu peux
mettre deux plus beaux yeux d'une c'est
ça [ __ ] mais c'est malin j'avais même
pas vu la référence puisque dans leur
film est créé ce pack coincé dix minutes
entre deux cailloux sinon c'est nul
et en plus ça sortirait pas au cinéma
bien sûr avec jcvd pas mal la nouvelle
arme ultime de kim jong-un c'est très
bien trouvé à temps mais il ya plus
d'efforts quoi il n'y a plus aucun
effort la période où au cvo celui ci
très très beau squeeze les affame mec
franchement c'est pas sympa de mettre la
vie privée des gens en avant comme ça ça
on passe un bac en squeeze voit une
fille trop belle réaction bizarre alors
marion chaude vergne tuant huit ans et
demi c'est sûr c'est obligatoire
ah ah lol désolé il ya encore le pont
vers nice battu parce tu peux pas faire
ça tu peux pas faire tourner en tâche de
dire désolé j'ai encore le faire ça ne
marche pas est ce que tu as vu avengers
est ce que tu as vu un fond vert avec
marc est désolé ya encore fonds vert on
appelle non on a un nouveau club pour le
prochain final fantasy et ben mec je
vais en parler à square enix et à moyens
qui me colle un procès vous n'auriez pas
vu l'inspiration parce que j'en manque
vraiment là au [ __ ] au squeeze
rencontre 3d squeeze what the fuck mec
tu t'es fait chier à modéliser un peu
mon décor en 3d bompas les figurines en
fallait pas fanées pas abuser quand même
mec c'est fou c'est beau il rencontre
jacques chiottes ça tourne mal c'est
beau très très belle affiche à temps et
a carrément reconstituer mon bras qui à
la base est coupée quoi c'est fou [ __ ]
aller voir ce film c'est énorme c'est
énorme
[Musique]
by the me fait rire c'est grave j'ai pas
ce qu'est le pire la qualité du montage
ou le fait que ça me fait rire eh bien
les abaisser à fort de cette vidéo où je
regarde tout au montage et ben merci
d'avoir pris le temps de faire ces
personnes n'étaient pas allés mais si
elle vous a plu il ya eu des trucs et
des perles il ya eu fraude il ya eu
celle ci aussi qui maritime a fait vomir
que vous avez fait un truc de perdre un
truc bien envoyé ses coups vous avez
pris le temps de faire quelque chose et
c'est très mignon ça valait le coup
d'attendre une nuit pour regarder tout
ça en vidéo
j'ai passé un bon moment à la tenue
prochaine vidéo je vous dis revoir
attention
[Musique]
ça